annonces douloureuses pour pascal
thévenot le député sortant donne les
résultats de sa commune vélizy
villacoublay
un an seulement après son élection il
voit son siège s'éloigner ici aussi
c'est le candidat de la république en
marche qui arrive en tête quand on voit
la macro magna qui a aujourd'hui il
suffit qu'ils traversent en fait à
chaque fois tout est miraculeux
non je pense que si on peut pas comparer
les choses et l'élection il ya un an a
été fait sur un projet sur un territoire
là on le voit quel que soit le candidat
de toute façon les gens ne votent pas
pour un candidat votre pour donner une
majorité présidentielle et on le voit
même dans d'autres circonscriptions donc
là il faut simplement réussir à
remobiliser les 50%
deux personnes qui sont pas allés voter
une tendance confirmée dans presque
toutes les communes de la 2e
circonscription
à l'issue de ce premier tour pascal
thévenot recueil -2 23% des suffrages
l'ingénieur chercheurs de 34 ans termine
en tête de ce premier tour
jean-noël barrot le candidat rer obtient
43 84 %
on n'avait pas vraiment du chiffre en
tatar bien sûr c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle pour nous ce soir mais on va
continuer à faire ce qu'on a fait
jusqu'à présent c'est à dire comme le
disait robert j'ai d'ailleurs une
campagne positive où on essaye de faire
un certain nombre de propositions qui
sont qui sont en partie celle qui a
porté et manille de la crau c'est ce
qu'on va continuer de faire cette
semaine
dix sept candidats se présentaient sur
la 2e circonscription le front national
représenté par yasmine bentele matt se
classe cinquième avec -2 6% des voix
loin du score réalisé par marine le pen
lors du premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle même tendance du côté de
la france insoumise marc soriano termine
troisième du scrutin avec 7% des voix
le 23 avril jean luc mélenchon obtenez
plus de 13% des suffrages
le résultat au niveau local pour moi
c'est très positif la france insoumise
représente la première force de gauche
on est loin derrière le deuxième mais on
est devant le
l'attelage verts communistes socialistes
on est devant donc les mouvements enfin
les partis qui représentent des
appareils les chiffres santé fou se
sentent absolument effrayant pour
quelqu'un qui connaît pas du tout la
circonscription qui a été bon élève à
hec mais bon je pense que c'est
suffisant
deux candidats sont donc qualifiés pour
le second tour de ces élections
législatives parmi les battus aucune
consigne de vote n'a été donnée